your surgeon may perform laparoscopic
lysis of adhesions or laparoscopic
adhesion from the organs in your abdomen
normally the surfaces of your abdominal
organs are slippery and move easily past
one another as you go about your daily
activities
if you have bands of scar tissue in your
abdomen called adhesions your abdominal
organs stick to each other or to the
abdominal wall
these adhesions can cause bowel
obstructions by constricting your
intestines or twisting or pulling them
out of place
partially or completely blocking food or
stool from moving through them if you
are a woman adhesions can also cause
infertility by twisting or pulling your
fallopian tubes out of place partially
or completely blocking fertilized eggs
from reaching your uterus where a baby
can grow and develop
the most common cause of abdominal
adhesions is abdominal surgery other
causes can be abdominal infections such
as peritonitis inflammatory conditions
such as appendicitis abdominal trauma or
radiation
before the procedure you will be given
general anesthesia which will put you to
sleep
your surgeon will inject gas into your
abdomen to expand the abdominal cavity
making it easier to see the structures
inside
then your surgeon will make a small
incision to access the inside of your
abdomen
he or she will insert a laparoscope
which contains a light a camera and a
magnifying device
the laparoscope will project images onto
a TV monitor to guide your surgeons work
after examining the abdominal cavity
your surgeon will make three or four
small incisions in your abdomen through
which to pass surgical tools
using these tools your surgeon will cut
the adhesions to free the organs from
each other once all of the adhesions are
divided your surgeon will remove the
laparoscopic tools and close the
incisions with stitches
after your procedure you will be
monitored in the recovery room you may
go home the same day or stay in the
hospital for up to three days to help
your recovery keep the incision sites
clean and dry take pain medication as
directed by your doctor
avoid heavy lifting and do not drink
carbonated beverages for two days